okay I don't know if you've been
following this story but a lot of people
have asked me to comment on it this is
the sort of CNN versus a troll blackmail
daxing story okay and you might not have
heard of this and the specifics of it
are less interesting than the
implications but I'll just catch you up
very quickly on what happened Donald
Trump recently tweeted out a meme okay
and he put this out on his Twitter
account with the hashtag fraud news CNN
and hashtag FNN suggesting fake news
network and the meme was a video of
Donald Trump who used to participate in
WWE or maybe at the time it was WWF
wrestling and he was wrestling someone
whose face was replaced by a CNN logo in
this video that was tweeted okay I'll
just show you what that looks like real
quick
[Applause]
okay all right good so that gives you an
idea right it's kind of funny I have no
problem with it it's not offensive it's
pretty clever Donald Trump has been at
war with CNN I think four completely
fabricated and bogus reasons but it's
funny to see a physical representation
of Donald Trump who used to participate
in wrestling events on TV tackling and
punching someone whose face was replaced
with the CNN logo it has nothing to do
with Trump's politics I just think it's
kind of funny eventually a user of the
internet forum reddit claimed
responsibility okay and there was a
reddit thread where they said wow I
never expected my meme to be retweeted
by the gods Emperor himself and it was
then found out that the same redditor
had a post history on reddit that was
sort of bizarre at best and horribly
racist at worst and the user has since
deleted their entire account off of
Reddit as well as all of their posts and
just as some examples a few days ago
this reddit user wrote quote most blacks
don't know who their fathers are in a
threat about how much money Americans
spend on the holidays like you know
Mother's Day Father's Day etc he said he
would get satisfaction out of seeing
billionaire investor and prominent
Democratic support urge or cirrhosis
quote dead bloated corpse being dragged
through the streets etc etc and
ultimately CNN put out an article
explaining that they actually tracked
down who this person was in real life
and they put out a statement about their
decision not to release the person's
identity and we're going to get to that
in a second so so far I wasn't offended
by this by this video I didn't find
anything particularly remarkable it's
kind of funny but it really did not seem
like a huge deal I mean yes the
president is retweeting something so
stupid but this is what he does Trump
tweets about stuff that's meaningless
while but you know while pulling out of
the Paris climate Accord that's not new
yeah I mean some may call it an attack
on the media but I think that's kind of
a flaccid critique because pretty much
everyone knows that wrestling is fake
and this is all just in good fun
but this is not the first time that
Donald Trump has retweeted content from
someone who regularly puts up
anti-semitic and racist material your
the black on black versus white on white
crime statistics your Hillary Clinton
with a that star of david' that said
most corrupt politician ever tour so it
long and short of it is yes this is sort
of weird behavior for a 71 year old man
or 70 year old man however old he is at
this point but it is consistent with his
past behavior so CNN tracks down who
this person that made the video is in
real life and they put out an article
saying quote CNN is not publishing on a
whole so loes name that's the reddit
username because he is a private citizen
who has issued an extensive statement of
apology showed his remorse by saying he
has taken down all his offending posts
and because he said he is not going to
repeat this ugly behavior on social
media again in addition he said his
statement could serve as an example to
others not to do the same
CNN decided not to publish the name of
the Reddit user out of concern for his
safety any assertion that the network
blackmailed or coerced him is false the
user who is an adult male not a 15 year
old boy apologized and deleted his
account before ever speaking with our
reporter so those are the allegations
right that CNN is refuting some are
saying this is blackmail saying hey if
he does X they will publish his identity
is this blackmail is CNN doing the right
thing by not publishing the guy's
information let's take it piece by piece
what is blackmail blackmail is the use
of threats or manipulation of feelings
to force someone to do something or when
it comes to money blackmail is money
demanded from someone in return for not
revealing damaging information money
isn't a part of this so so the question
is where threats or manipulation used to
force them to do something or even not
force but compel well CNN said we found
your identity if you do this again we
will release your information it's not
force I guess it's barely compelling
it's sort of persuasion I guess the
other issue is that none of the
information that CNN said they would
release
if this guy did X Y or Z is secret
information the reddit user went on
reddit and publicly took credit for the
meme so they outed themselves as a
redditor and then anyone could just you
know look up the guys basic identity
information or do a search for the
reddit username to cross-reference it
with other websites or whatever this was
not secret information to begin with now
CNN could take the position that while
the person may not have considered
themselves a public figure that once
they did this and once they took credit
for it on reddit publicly which they
didn't have to do they chose to go on
Reddit and do that they have now
volunteered themselves in a public way
and thus that's it they are there now
public in the sense of finding out who
the person is which probably happened by
looking at their post history and
googling the reddit username you know I
think we can have a reasonable
conversation over whether this is
coercion or daxing or blackmail
what-have-you but to me it just comes
down to don't post offensive material on
the Internet under the guise of
anonymity and then try to blame the
victim but or try to play the victim
after that particularly after you take
responsibility for it no one forced him
to go on the donald subreddit and do
that so i think this sounds more like a
threat to Docs but barely because again
this information could have been found
by by by many people this is an adult
who outed themselves on the Internet
CNN is really not the problem here I do
think here's the problem with CNN this
is nonsense why is a news entity the
size and scope of CNN even looking for
the identity of this person and putting
out statements about the fact that
they've uncovered the identity if you
ever have have heard the term punching
down this is punching down see what I'm
embarrassed by here in for CNN is that
they even wasted time
don't even mention this guy right pat
that's my perspective don't get involved
in what some random person did on the
Internet don't give them the time of day
don't give them the satisfaction of
knowing that they seem to have gotten
under your skin don't waste time on this
and that's the real problem I have with
it it does seem as though
so they're trying to put themselves on
the same level as this reddit poster
where really they're broadcasting in so
many homes around the world that they're
far above him and it kind of plays into
this idea that you know maybe they are
fake news as Donald Trump opposes the
the mere involvement that they
participated in as a result of this only
fuels the fake news stuff from Trump and
the trumpets that have bought into it
hook line and sinker and that's why I
think it was just a total strategic
mistake by CNN